[Musique]
marilou cherche une voiture dans les
petites annonces sur internet
elle tombe sur une occasion incroyable
bien équipée jamais accidentée peu
kilométrage et un prix en dessous du
marché par courriel de vendeurs explique
à marilou qu'il vient de déménager à
l'étranger et qu'il veut vendre
rapidement le vendeur affirme avoir
confié loto à une compagnie de transport
et lui demande un dépôt de 1000 $ par
l'entremise de services de transfert
d'argent marie lou a peur de manquer
cette occasion et s'empresse d'envoyer
l'argent mais les jours passent et elle
est incapable de joindre le vendeur elle
fait des recherches sur internet et se
rend compte que ce genre d' annonce est
une fraude répandue elle s'est fait
avoir
évidemment marilou n'aurait jamais dû
envoyer d'argent sans voir le véhicule
et le certificat d'immatriculation
le fin mot de l'histoire si quelque
chose est trop beau pour être vrai c'est
que ça l'est